[Music]
it's much closer than than everyone
thought so I I still think Madras is
Spencer's chances are slightly more
favorable one of the reasons is that he
had a lot of experience playing Walsh
ambition patches and it for Fabiana is
the first time so and when people think
oh so what's the big deal so he won't
jump into bad you play other matches
well championship matches is quite a
special experience and and it will be
quite challenging pretty much just to
get adjusted so just to do this
challenge but there's also pressure on
magnet shoulders and last time with
Kuryakin we're in the match where I
believe he was a big favorite his
psychological stability wasn't it was in
question its I think just it's a matches
so close and I think this only after
couple of opening games we can actually
understand you know what is the what is
the mood was a psychology sort of behind
these games and how the players yes I
coping with this with this business
pressure let's say I will not be
surprised by any result of the match
Fabiano's very consistent solid
performance over last 12 months in appoo
team on the second position you know
literally within was in a striking
distance from magnets but at the end of
the day rating is rating it's it's all
about moves they will make in London
they call of the moves and and the
strengths of character that each of them